Fearless, relentless, and one of the most
utterly brutal warriors to ever walk the face
of the Earth, with a body count somewhere
in the high hundred thousands; if not well
into multiple millions given just how long
he’s been around for.
Many of you will already be well aware of
SCP-076-2, also known as Able.
On the surface, he’s a man of Middle Eastern
descent, covered in tattoos of occult symbols
and demonic faces.
Usually contained within a stone cube designated
SCP-076-1, Able will often emerge in a homicidal
state, killing anyone and anything directly
around him.
How?
Well, by any means available to him, but primarily
by pulling a wide array of bladed weapons
seemingly out of thin air.
This is thanks to a tiny pocket dimension
that only he can reach into, which is also
always stocked with an assortment of deadly
implements for his latest murder spree.
As if being highly combat proficient and always
armed didn’t make him enough of an imposing
threat, SCP-076-2 also possesses a near superhuman
resistance to damage, making him incredibly
difficult to take down.
And even if someone is able to eventually
neutralize him, Able will also come back,
resurrecting inside SCP-076-1 to fight another
day.
What you may not know is, for a time, Able
actually worked alongside the SCP Foundation.
Although, nowadays, they prefer to keep him
locked away in a secure containment facility
underwater, which they will flood with seawater
if he ever escapes.
But Able was once appointed the leader of
his own Mobile Task Force, Omega 7, referred
to under the codename of ‘Pandora’s Box’.
You see, the Foundation realized that SCP-076-2
held an especially high regard for those who
proved – well, able – to best him in combat.
And it was this strange code of honor that
Able held that the Foundation hoped to exploit
with the creation of Pandora’s Box, comprised
of MTF operatives that had earned Able’s
respect, most by previously beating him in
a fair fight.
Or as fair as a fight with a man who can summon
swords through a tear in the fabric of reality
can be.
These agents would support Able during missions
in the field, during which the SCP Foundation
were able to deploy the anomalous warrior
in various tactical engagements.
However, this didn’t last long.
Eventually, Able grew tired of carrying out
the orders of the Foundation.
The immortal warrior craved a challenge, breaking
free of containment and turning on the Foundation,
resulting in Able being neutralized by an
on-site nuclear weapon.
This marked the end of the fragile alliance
between SCP-076-2 and the SCP Foundation,
leaving the existence of Omega 7 a classified
secret, and one of the organization’s most
embarrassing missteps.
But what if that hadn’t happened?
What if, out there in the infinite multiverse,
there was a world where Able had been allowed
to remain a part of Omega 7, and the Mobile
Task Force was never disbanded?
Well, you’re about to find out.
In our world, Able’s dissatisfaction with
being a member of Pandora’s Box first became
apparent when he began putting the rest of
his unit through live-fire exercises, brutalizing
his men despite these exercises being intended
as for training purposes only.
But in this world, the injuries and even casualties
Able inflicted on the rest of Omega 7 were
met with a much different response.
The O5 Council of this alternate version of
the SCP Foundation, viewed Able’s outbursts
during training as acceptable losses.
Every time he would injure one of Omega 7,
the Council would demand that replacements
be on hand to become part of the task force,
drawn from the ranks of the other MTFs at
their disposal.
After all, Able was a valuable asset for carrying
out the Foundation’s dirty work.
By continually replenishing his team with
reserves from their seemingly inexhaustible
supply of other MTF agents, the O5 Council
of this work were able to keep SCP-076-2 firmly
under their employ.
However, it’s also important to note that
Able’s patience for these new recruits was
far more limited than the original Omega 7s.
Those men had all been hand-picked by Able
personally and appointed to the project, given
that he had some modicum of respect for them
as combatants.
Whereas all of their replacements were plucked
at random from the Foundation’s other MTFs.
As a result, SCP-076-2 would carelessly kill
or wound more and more of these reserves during
combat missions, hardly distinguishing between
friend and foe.
But despite this, the O5 Council refused to
discontinue the Omega 7 project, viewing these
as acceptable losses, and letting the success
rate of Able’s missions justify the depletion
of their other Mobile Task Forces.
Under Able’s leadership and the commands
of the O5 Council, Omega 7 would become this
Foundation’s primary rapid response unit
and the most deployed task force for dangerous
field operations.
And working for the Foundation meant that
every field mission was a highly dangerous
one.
Such was the case during one containment breach
where SCP-682 managed to get free of its acid
tank.
A rampaging, infinitely adaptable Hard to
Destroy Reptile on the loose, slaughtering
all in its path, was bad enough.
But the O5 Council had received intel that
there was something more behind this breakout
than it first seemed.
And so, Able and the rest of his latest Omega
7 team were sent in to pacify SCP-682.
Bursting into the facility, eager to once
again be freed from containment and the monotonous,
underwhelming experience of training, Able
flew into combat.
Drawing black swords from his personal armory,
he began to tear through everything and everyone
in his path.
Unfortunately, for the Foundation personnel
on site, this also meant they were subject
to Able’s relentless wrath.
As if running away from SCP-682 wasn’t bad
enough, fleeing research staff were quickly
met with the swing of SCP-076-2’s weapons,
and removed from the premises in a brutal
fashion.
Still, this meant little to Able, and even
less to the O5 Council.
As far as they were concerned, even their
own staff were just collateral damage, more
acceptable losses justified by Able’s perfect
record for successful, high-risk, high-reward
field missions.
However, that perfect record was about to
be tarnished for good…
You see, this containment breach wasn’t
your average SCP-682 escape attempt.
It was instead a situation that had been meticulously
planned and carried out for one purpose.
This breach was intended specifically to draw
Able out.
Since he had become the SCP Foundation’s
primary weapon and response to danger in the
field, a particularly devious third party
had begun to take note.
The Chaos Insurgency, a splinter faction that
began its life as an off-the-books black ops
unit for the Foundation themselves, had been
monitoring Able’s deployment by the O5 Council.
In this universe, their origin was the same
as in ours, and the Insurgency took a certain
disdain to seeing an anomalous individual
carrying out the kind of operations their
group had been formed to undertake for the
Foundation.
Additionally, the use of SCP-076-2 as a personal
attack dog by the O5 Council is hypocrisy.
The Insurgency believed in the practical application
of anomalies rather than locking them up and
keeping them contained, and it was for this
belief that they had been vilified by the
Foundation.
And yet, here was the same organization, sending
Able on missions, with no care for the harm
he caused.
And so, as a result, the Chaos Insurgency
had conducted an operation to break into the
Foundation, free SCP-682 and send the Hard
to Destroy Reptile on a rampage, all so they
could take their shot at Able.
Being ambushed by a group of Chaos Insurgency
operatives on his way to engage SCP-682, Able
was admittedly caught by surprise.
But by now, his combat prowess was second
to almost nobody else in the world.
The Insurgents dogpiled on Able, unleashing
every ounce of firepower they had brought
to bear on the immortal warrior.
The ensuing firefight destroyed an entire
wing of the Foundation facilities, explosive
weapons being detonated in the hopes that
the Insurgency could subdue Able.
All the while, SCP-076-2 shrugged off the
oncoming damage, catching rockets that were
launched at him and throwing them back in
the direction of the Chaos Insurgents.
It was a bloodbath, nearly the entire Omega
7 team that had been accompanying Able and
providing him with fire support were lying
dead.
The same could also be said for the Insurgency
forces too, though, with each of them being
gradually felled by the warrior's many weapons.
But by this point, Able was approaching exhaustion,
and there was still one more enemy left standing.
It had been unfurling destruction all of its
own, angrily devouring the few Foundation
personnel that were left.
And now, the scaly form of SCP-682 came lumbering
around the corner.
The battle was brutal; in this universe, Able
and the Hard to Destroy Reptile had never
crossed paths before.
But SCP-682 could smell the difference in
Able’s physiology, his innate ability to
resist damage and resurrect time and time
again.
The creature already held disdain for anything
and everything living, and so, presented with
a man who technically couldn’t stop living,
SCP-682 entered an unstoppable rage state,
taking the exhausted Able down with ease.
But losing in a grudge match against SCP-682
wasn’t quite as bad as things were about
to get for Able.
Reviving inside his stone cube, the ancient
warrior was confused; the Foundation weren’t
letting him out.
It had been a long time, years even, since
he had last ‘died’ even temporarily.
Over the course of all his Omega 7 missions,
he hadn’t needed to reappear back inside
SCP-076-1 for quite a considerable while.
And now that he had, a very large seed of
doubt had been sown.
The O5 Council were furious, just as angry
at SCP-076-2’s apparent failure as Able
was.
The perfect operational track record of their
top anomalous asset was now tarnished.
The question started to spread through the
council members; if their sword-wielding,
virtually invulnerable secret weapon wasn’t
as effective as they had previously thought,
then what was the use of continuing to deploy
Able?
And so began a debate within the O5 Council,
upon what was to be the fate of SCP-076-2.
In this universe, he had served the Foundation
well, but a weapon that is only effective
even 90% of the time still leaves a margin
of error.
It was that risk, that potential for error,
knowing that Able wouldn’t always succeed
in his missions, that caused the O5 Council
to reconsider his applications as a field
operative.
There were some in the Council who argued
that this was a highly specific, isolated
incident.
The Chaos Insurgency had specifically engineered
the SCP-682 escape as a way to draw Able out,
after all.
Just because he had failed this time didn’t
indicate a pattern of failure.
But this argument was eventually shot down,
especially when the Foundation’s Ethics
Committee decided to throw in their two cents.
They demanded Able’s status as a field agent
be revoked, and levied for the immediate disbanding
of the Omega 7 project.
Pooling replacements for that task force from
other MTFs at the Foundation had left them
with a significantly depleted reserve of troops.
And then came the argument about just how
‘acceptable’ the losses were whenever
Able was let loose.
A decision was ultimately made to – at least
for the moment – rescind SCP-076-2’s field
operative privileges and suspend any further
deployment of or recruitment into Omega 7.
However, there was one crucial factor that
nobody on the Council had taken into consideration
when they made their verdict: and that was
how badly Able would react to the news.
As you may already have predicted, Able was
furious to hear he would be held in containment
until further notice.
His anger stemmed not only from his defeat
at the jaws of SCP-682, but at how quick the
Foundation seemingly was to question his combat
prowess.
He’d lost one battle out of hundreds – thousands
even – and all of a sudden the O5 Council
were going to lock him away?
All because of one defeat?
“You dare!”
Able bellowed when he was given the news.
“I am the greatest warrior on this planet,
and have been made a pawn by your Foundation.
I give you my strength, my skill, and the
moment I falter, you turn your back on me?
You dare?
YOU DARE?!
I WILL SHOW YOU WHAT REAL POWER LOOKS LIKE!”
Overcome with rage, it didn’t take long
for Able to force his way out of containment.
He’d been active as a field agent within
the Foundation for so long now that he had
long since figured out a way to escape his
underwater prison before the emergency containment
measures had a chance to stop him.
As he broke free, he made sure to take down
plenty of security staff on the way.
And to make matters worse, he didn’t stop
there.
Before long, Able was on the warpath against
the SCP Foundation.
Every few days, reports would come in of a
massacre at a Foundation facility.
Security footage recovered from the wreckage
after each incident would show Able arriving
primed for battle, a sword in each hand.
By the time he left after his brutal, remorseless
attack, he’d be drenched in the blood of
the entire Site’s personnel.
The Foundation had little in its once huge
arsenal to fight back with.
Given the number of MTF agents reassigned
to Omega 7, their forces were far more limited,
if not almost depleted.
They dispatched attachments to clean up the
wake of Able’s destruction, but not one
squad sent after the anomalous warrior came
back alive.
Part of the problem was, the Foundation couldn’t
predict where Able would show up next, or
which of their Sites he knew about and was
planning to hit.
From their perspective, his attacks were spontaneous,
the result of rage at the Foundation, but
without any premeditated plan in mind.
And that was exactly what Able wanted them
to think.
By seeming to attack at random, he was, therefore,
able to cover the true intention behind each
engagement: he was looking for something.
During his considerable time leading Omega
7, he had heard about a machine that could
improve anything placed inside it: SCP-914,
better known as the Clockworks.
And before long, Able found what he was looking
for.
By the time the Foundation realized what the
unstoppable warrior’s plan was, it was already
too late.
Able was storming into the facility that housed
SCP-914, with no intention of leaving until
he’d used it.
The Foundation had banned testing of biological
matter within the Clockworks, but Able wasn’t
beholden to their rules anymore.
In fact, he barely was when he’d worked
with them before.
Cutting down guards and researchers, survivors
fleeing in terror, Able stepped up towards
the mass of gears and cogs, the clockwork
components that made up SCP-914.
He wasted no time, setting the machine to
‘Very Fine’.
With this setting, the Clockworks would take
whatever was in its Input booth and improve
it, usually by giving it anomalous properties.
Or, in the case of Able, by giving him further
anomalous properties.
Stepping inside, the whirr of machinery drowned
out the emergency alarms, as Able reached
his goal… to become the ultimate warrior,
the embodiment of the very concept itself.
Racing to the scene, a chopper cleared the
smoke as it approached.
Under an emergency executive order from the
O5 Council, the few surviving remnants of
the Foundation’s Mobile Task Forces had
been combined into a singular strike team.
There weren’t many left, considering how
many others from their units had been previously
siphoned into Omega 7, only to die as collateral
damage in that team’s missions with Able.
“Remember, SCP-076-2 is a priority target!”
the field commander barked, while the MTF
strike team held their guns nervously aboard
the aircraft.
“Primary objective is to neutralize him
by any means.
Reports indicate that he may be trying to
access SCP-914, so be advised-”
An almighty explosion boomed through the airborne
vehicle, engulfing the cockpit in flames.
“Mayday, mayday; Chopper One has been hit,
we are going down!!”
the commander radioed to Foundation command.
“Everyone brace yourselves for impact.”
The helicopter spiraled out of the air, crashing
to the ground in a twisted hunk of metal.
The surviving members of the strike team scrabbled
out of the wreckage, hauling the more badly
wounded out of the ruined aircraft.
“Contact!”
someone yelled in horror.
“Enemy contact behind us!”
The remaining Foundation foot soldiers turned
and drew their weapons, opening fire on something
suspended a few feet in the air above them.
A hail of gunfire rang out, as the team opened
fire the second that they saw who it was…
it was Able, and he was flying.
Floating above them, his hair whipping in
the wind, the oncoming storm of bullets seemed
to ricochet off his skin.
In actuality, they weren’t even hitting
him; melting away before they could make contact.
They might as well have been firing pea shooters
for how little effect their guns had.
The barrage only stopped when one of the strike
team launched a short-range rocket at the
newly refined warrior.
It detonated, but when the smoke from the
blast cleared, Able was still hovering in
the air, without so much as a scratch.
“My turn,” he announced.
Reaching into his pocket dimension, Able pulled
something out: not a weapon, not yet.
Instead, it was a formless, dark, shadowy
mass, that moved like liquid metal, reacting
to the movement of his hand.
As he drew the substance out, it reformed,
seemingly at Able’s command.
And it wasn’t just swords he could create
now.
Drawing on his experiences from his Omega
7 missions, any weapon that Able had previously
seen or could think of, he now had at his
disposal.
The strike team looked up in horror as a veritable
swarm of black, non-reflective constructs
hovered in the air on either side of Able;
each one in the shape of a rocket.
Flinging both arms toward the Foundation troops.
Able sent his new creations raining down on
them.
The strike team turned heel and fled for their
lives, although none of them got very far.
Able’s rockets engulfed the area around
them in a volley of explosions, leaving not
a single living thing standing.
He had just effortlessly built an airstrike
from virtually thin air and thrown it at the
Foundation’s last remaining MTF agents…
and he wasn’t done there.
With his newfound powers, Able’s campaign
of destruction swept the entire world.
In a last act of desperation, the SCP Foundation
offered freedom to any anomaly that permanently
took down SCP-076-2.
They all flooded out of containment to take
their shot, the Plague Doctor, the Shy Guy,
The Specter… and they barely slowed Able
down.
His new constructs were devastating weapons,
taking the form of not just blades, but projectiles
of every size and shape; all of them lethal.
Before long, Able had lain waste to the entire
Foundation.
But still, he wanted more.
SCP-914 hadn’t just improved Able’s existing
anomalous powers and granted him the ability
to fly at supersonic speeds, but in doing
so, had amplified his rage too.
He loathed the human race, and sought to absolutely
decimate every single living thing.
No one could best him in combat now, and in
his mind, twisted by anger, not one of them
was worthy of his respect.
He tore planes apart with his bare hands,
smashed tanks to pieces, and leveled entire
cities with his unlimited weapons.
It took a few years, maybe a decade at the
most.
But by the end of it, Able was sat atop a
pile of billions upon billions of bones.
With his refined abilities, he had done something
unthinkable: committed omnicide.
He had killed everyone in the world.
Of course, this was indeed another world,
one different to ours.
Luckily, here, our version of Able is still
locked up underwater.
But somewhere out there, the is an Able who
is watching the sun rising over an entirely
dead world.
His world.
Want to own an SCP of your own?
Go to scpswag.com for premium anomalous merchandise!
Now to see the result of more anomalous experiments
with the Clockworks, go and check out “WHAT
IF SCP-096 WAS PUT INSIDE SCP-914?”
and “SCP-914 WHAT DID YOU PUT IN IT?!”